hello everyone welcome to the supper
suite at South by Southwest brought to
you by El Tesoro tequila and Blue Moon
we are so excited to be here today
because we're talking about the movie
yes god yes I want to welcome you all
thank you so much for your time today
just to jump right in I was curious
because making a first feature is not
easy so what was the process in terms of
going from the short to the feature did
you just wake up one morning and say I
need to make this story a full feature
well it's interesting because the
feature was written right after we
finished writing obvious child I wanted
to tell this story so the feature
existed before the short film so the
short was adapted from the feature
script and we did it as a
proof-of-concept to sort of prove that I
could direct and then we got those money
to make the feature oh man so the the
money part is what intimidates me the
most so given the success of the short
was that fairly easy for you this time
or was there any kind of convincing on
your end that still needed to happen I
mean yeah there's a lot of convincing
involved I feel like we got off pretty
easy I think it you know you read about
films like the favorite which took like
so long I don't even know how long it is
but a very long time from script to
actual film so for us it was about a
year before we had financing and could
shoot the film so we were very lucky I
think it's great I'm glad it worked out
because the short is something else and
I could see like exact copies from the
short in the feature and I think that's
a really nice touch I'm curious and
Tahlia for you going from the short to
the feature like had you actually read
the feature script before you did the
short no no I hadn't I yeah I just got
those this this short in my in my inbox
and got it and I was like this is
hilarious and I'm a big fan of obvious
child and you know and Karen has such a
funny great voice and her writing so it
was just going to like you know I I I
think you did say that there is always
gonna be there's always kind of this
idea of having it
a longer feature about it but yeah I
didn't read it until after the short
came out and it's you know it's it's
great I think it what's lovely is it
really kind of it has all that those fun
you know and funny beats of the short
but you got you know it just really
fills it out and touching on some deeper
I think topics within that world but
yeah I was I mean she like I said she's
a great writer so it was it was you know
happy to read stepping back into the
project was it almost like you know you
remembered exactly what it was like on
the short or was it a different feel
yeah I mean there's some similar you
know I do you guys going on because it
was you know taken from with the future
length but you know these guys into the
mix made you know made a huge difference
and brought a really fun and funny vibe
to the set and we were we were so we
shot the short in New York but for the
feature we were in a completely
different place and kind of the the
place the coast where we were filming
it's all felt very secluded so it was
kind of I don't know it was great I
can't imagine a better location for it
was it an actual camp I mean did it have
that kind of you know on location you're
out there camping kind of vibe did you
guys get to make s'mores because that's
the key it stressed me out that you held
this more in the movie and didn't eat it
we all work we all work in film none of
us that have had a s'more in like 15
years I'm curious now how the whole
ensemble came together I'm obsessed with
the game six degrees of Kevin Bacon so
this might be me reading the into this
too much but it's like I see stranger
things connections in the cast here I
know Sierra Burgess and then I could
loop it back to stranger things did you
guys all kind of know each other was
there any kind of you know tipping off
the casting director in terms of
bringing you all together
No yeah no we found everybody sort of
separately I didn't know that anybody
knew each other so and and Fran and and
Natalia the stranger things happen after
yes god yes things after finishing this
movie and so my first day on set was my
first time meeting Natalia so it was
just kind of I I had been doing theatre
in London at the time and I got a call
from my agent to tape for yes god yes
but the deadline was in like three hours
because of the time difference so I
watch the short film read the script and
then didn't have enough time to get off
book so I had a friend of mine write out
the lines off camera I sent in the tape
and I didn't hear anything for six
months and then January 2nd
not even though they liked it you're in
nothing and then six months later the
day January 2nd I fly back from New York
and Christmas break and I get a call
from my agent saying you're gonna
FaceTime with the director of yes god
yes tomorrow morning and my first
thought is what the hell is yes god yes
and then I was like oh I remember I
remember and then the next morning I
FaceTime with Karen and we kind of just
had a really easy rapport and talked
about the scenes that I had taped for
she gave me direction for each scene and
irie taped and two weeks later I was on
set this is gonna sound like a really
weird question but I have to ask it were
you just having like hair taped to your
arms that is the art the arm hair is not
mine
but I've been told by people close to me
they're like was that your so I think it
works and it's real but he would take
about an hour in the morning to put on
and the first day we did it was like a
sleeve of real hair but Karen said it
didn't look so good on camera so then
going forward it was like a it was like
a werewolf and then going forward we did
individual hair each day and then I
couldn't cross my arms together because
if I did my arms would stick together
and it took about a half hour half hour
every night to take off
it's the little things that we don't
think about I definitely would agree
it's like noticeable as it should be but
it doesn't look unrealistic which is
quite the achievement I was going down
you know the Google whole to basically
prepare for this interview and I came
across all your basketball stuff and I'm
a little obsessed with basketball so I
have to bring it up are you still
playing I know I was I was a basketball
playing my entire life and I was a
preparing to play a kind of big-time
Division one college basketball and then
my senior of high school I started
acting for the first time and made a
decision to stop playing basketball and
go to theater school in London Wow
but what what kind of nudged you in that
direction was there any specific
inspiration a movie you saw a
performance you saw I've always loved
movies but um yeah it was just I just
remember feeling like visiting all these
colleges I'd worked my whole life for a
feeling of kind of completion and I'd
found a new love and I was like I want
to do this now now you just need a movie
to cast a basketball star and like
you've got it may the best of both
worlds well see we'll see I was a little
curious about the idea to set this movie
in the 90s because I definitely grew up
in the late 90s early 2000 I grew up in
this time period and I was telling
everybody I vividly remember my first I
am on AOL so did you consider you know
what someone like me would think about
this but also kids that are growing up
today who basically had iPhones and
Internet access since birth yeah it's
interesting I can't speak for the
younger generally speak for that part of
the question but I said it
yeah it's set in the early 2000s
actually no different you know twofold
because I was that age as well when I
was growing up and it was a big part of
you know discovering sexuality and sex
stuff because you know the internet was
so new at that time that it isn't like a
vast world that it is now it was just
sort of slowly becoming something where
you could get information but it wasn't
as big as it is right now so I think
it's a very interesting point for the
internet where like Alice the main
character can't go out
and be like you know like what what is
tossing someone salad you know I mean
she could but I don't know if she'd get
the right and it's just like you're
still living within your own world much
more in the early aughts I think then
you were would be today because of the
internet so I wanted to have the
character have a more like sort of
secluded a society in which she lives
where she didn't couldn't get all the
answers on her fingertips essentially I
love how casually you say that - just
like tossing someone salad like it's
like no big deal at all but in this
movie is it difficult to kind of deal
with that kind of material and not like
I don't know like laughs to yourself or
feel awkward and just kind of strip that
all the way and dive into it well we had
a lot of trouble filming one scene I was
talking about water shooting up one's
beer but yeah that took a very long time
for Natalia dying to do at one point I
just stopped looking at her I just
completely changed my eyeline away from
her because I couldn't and we could hear
a Karen being like it's really funny we
have to we have to get it because we
just couldn't handle it same with Tim
Tim view doing a scene with you is
incredibly hard I try to make it
difficult I don't know I'm not gonna say
I'm unprofessional other others were
saying others would say how the others
would say but you know what whose
definition are we going by no I know
that
no I guess really what I just want to
says I want to thank our sponsors l
torso torso supper club yeah Austin
supper club and of course Cadillac thank
you for having us and and blue moon of
course too
going back to the the early 2000s
references I'm curious just because so
many things caught my eye caught my ear
is there any particular thing that you
guys thought was I don't know like your
favorite song to hear your favorite
movie to bring up anything along those
lines Mandy Moore Mandy Moore was huge I
feel like we all kind of yeah we're so
using we were on like the fade out of a
I am into texting like a messenger we
kind of caught the tail end yeah we did
it was like fancier looking not that
fancy
my name is very fancy how was it fancy
I'm the I'm good all the colors did you
change the colors of yours yeah I had it
my mine was like in the x-ray so it
looks very high-tech I don't know where
that look
yeah you do yeah but it's definitely
weird to tell people that there's she
gets in an AI am shot and have some
younger people look at me and be like
what is that do you remember your first
a old screen name oh yeah I have two
really bad ones
means well the first ones like normal
it's a crazy bananers and then my second
my second one my mother helped me come
up with and it's fierce euro chick 97
yeah I sound like a prostitute honestly
but yeah it was what's yours
please be more embarrassing my name is I
think it was Fran the Panda for eight
something the three numbers and then I
changed it to Fran L real but I spell my
last name wrong so no that's how it was
REE L like a real oh okay the city
baller that's th e not da hai UN spell
that's all I'm gonna say about that I
was on the tail end of this so I think I
was like it I think I was in a junior or
senior in high school in all this but I
think I was man-beast 37
yeah 36 other man bees there were 36
other man beasts that I had to get
through I had a I had a burner account
though it was el Tercero health and the
Austin supper club yeah maybe so do you
remember yours Oh mine's the one in the
film loves to ski oh okay that's a nice
edge I don't know why I'm telling the
story right now but when my little
sister made her she's gonna kill me for
saying this we used to call her Pigpen
as a kid so she wanted to make the the
AOL screen name Pigpen is for me six cuz
it's her lucky not did anybody figure it
out Pigpen is for me no yeah like if you
put all those words together what is
something dirty it's very dirty so she
could not have that but we tried and
couldn't figure out why it wouldn't work
for a very long time yes I just saw last
night that the Father Murphy's screen
name was it Saul to Paul 777 what is
that what is the biblical reference
that's there Saul was a Jew and he
became a Christian and he changed his
name to Paul so I just thought that was
the ultimate like I don't know it's like
a subtle I guess it's like a Murphy's
fight the sevens the holiest number in
the Bible so yeah the triple miss I
don't know why I just I didn't think too
hard about it but I thought yeah Saul de
Paul is like a big you know we got
another one so I feel like a lot of
times when we talk about the internet
and constantly being online it's usually
with a little bit of a negative spin on
it today so I was just wondering what's
one thing that you do on the internet or
on your phone that actually kind of
brings joy to your life on a regular
basis oh oh my god
looking posting pictures of my dog that
is the best answer I don't know how any
one's gonna top that I like educating
people on the dangers of vaccines
you think I'm thinking about is WebMD
there's this really cool Twitter page
accountant said ring there's a really
cool Twitter page called them we're
eight dog oh I love I know about that
which is I showed you we're eight dog
you don't even I've showed everyone in
this past we're eight dogs they're all
very good points 12 out of 10 you know I
gotta say probably is the only one up
here who's never had social media in my
entire life and I just recently made an
Instagram that seeing photos of like old
friends who I like went to middle school
with because like I grew up in New York
and I live in Los Angeles now and kind
of seeing even people I haven't spoken
to in a long time kind of seeing how
their lives are doing or what college
are doing at they're doing at college
that's cool to see that was a really
touching answer that I wasn't expecting
after all that alright to wrap up here
we're gonna play a game I'll just give
you guys the option would you rather do
random questions or would you rather
okay would you rather it is decision for
the group actually I planned that so
they're all moviemaking Film Festival
questions so feel free to just shout out
an answer whoever wants to would you
rather see your movie before its
Festival premiere or with the premiere
audience with the premiere audience yeah
I think for this one specifically Tim
and I saw the movie last week together
just the two of us seeing it with an
audience though was just a completely
different experience because you just
see just the energy in different moments
that you thought you know you reacted
you thought was funny is is so widely
different for somebody else so it was
pretty infectious last night in the
theater it was definitely a loud
response last night oh yeah I'd rather
watch it before I mean yesterday was my
second time watching it and I actually
got to watch the movie first time I was
watching
I was just looking at my face and I was
just like your face is just what is it
doing and I saw all these problems that
were non-existent I was like my my face
is like open and melting and shifting
and I feel the same way
yeah about you I mean about you yeah I
would say that's kind of tricky because
there do I do they're like you were
saying there's definitely such a value
in seeing it with other people
especially because of that reason
because it's very hard to watch yourself
on screen and like have any sort of
distance or any kind of perspective
really so I do think there's a benefit
of seeing an audience but I also think
I'd like to see it before just so just
you know something xiety is a little
more chill my face is melting every
single time i rewatch one of these
interviews by the right i think the same
exact thing there's a non description
but I think I'm gonna keep applying
that's what goes through my head now
right here's another one would you
rather meet a new collaborator at a film
festival or reconnect with someone you
work with long ago I keep up with old
friends and collaborators already so I'd
use it as opportunity people why I think
with this movie we filmed it you know
about nine ten months ago and I haven't
really seen everybody since then and you
know like the rest of the cast came and
Katy and Colleen and Karen so it's been
really fun to reconnect this weekend
would you rather do festival interviews
with a co-star who talks too much or not
enough too much yeah save me for myself
if it's Tim talking too much than Tim I
mean is the co-star talking about the
MMR vaccine that's what if it's not one
or the other it's not one of the other
than no I'm sure I can just do all my
press with Tim even if he's not in the
movie just have him there would you
rather mess up every single take
yourself or have somebody else mess up
your best take I know I'd rather mess it
up myself
yeah I think thank you know money can
only blame yourself yes yes if a phone
goes off and you're crying does that
happen on self it's an audition but
ready no I was on set I was crying and I
was like banging a wall and this
ringtone went off like I'm not even sure
what the tune was but it was not a song
that was in English and I everyone just
started laughing I'm still crying I
would say as deeply unprofessional as I
have been in this interview I would hate
myself if I blew somebody else's take
like I'm if I blew my own takes like all
right just get it together but if I blew
somebody else's I would feel terrible I
am in that boat I have a very guilty
conscience so I'd rather just like play
it cool if somebody else messed up I did
yeah all right would you rather would
you rather have to fake sneeze or fake
vomit in the scene fake vomit thankfully
it's cooler thanks this is hard no not
necessarily like even just doing like a
dry convinced I'm a method actor so I do
both for real every time on cue thank
you
it's more fun she's cooler when you see
it in like you know all these like kind
of gross at comedies and coming out I
imagine like the tube or whatever
they're using I don't know it seems like
a fun experience that's not the right
way the perhaps people are not worried
about what it tastes like they're
worried about texture in color and then
just put it in your mouth and spit it
into the sink but I would still probably
choose vomit only because I don't think
I could sneeze convincingly that's the
problem to wrap this up now I was just
wondering and you can all try min a
little bit here what you're kind of
hoping people take away from this movie
because I found that whether you're
religious or not and you can directly
relate to specifically what these
characters are going through there's so
many just broader things that somebody
can connect to and learn from where if
this movie was in my life back when I
was using AOL for the very first time
probably would have had a positive
effect on me I hope people there's just
a more open dialogue about young women
sexuality and experiencing pleasure
there's a really great book by peggy
orenstein that came out a few years ago
where she's interviews young women at
college and in high school about their
about sex and you know it's there's such
an expectation placed on like doing
things for men and and pleasing them
whereas the the female pleasure is
always secondary and it's in its you
know I understand why it's that way
because we talk about procreation and
you know men need to come to make a baby
so it's often just skimmed over the idea
that women can't even experience
pleasure or how they experience pleasure
both for men and women
so just to open the dialogue more and to
include in all sex ed classes a bit
about female sexual pleasure would be
great the microwave and oven thing made
a little too much sense I think also it
really comes together and I really
wonderfully at the end with natales a
big speech to everyone of kind of saying
that everybody's dealing with their own
things and some people are hiding things
and just trying to figure
it out and you're not gonna go to hell
if you're you know you do one thing and
you're a bad person you're a good person
it's not so black and white everybody's
just kind of trying to figure it out and
just kind of you know your body is your
friend it's not it's not your enemy it's
not there to make you feel terrible it's
there to make you feel empowered and we
should be more aware of that especially
as women especially now
body's a temple guys don't let a doctor
talking to anything you don't want to do
behind yes god yes
check it out keep an eye out for it also
another thank you for El Tesoro and also
the supper suite thank you for giving us
a home and for being able to talk about
movies like yes god yes thank you guys
again we will see you soon with more
South by Southwest coverage